gravitational waves are such a difficult
concept when Einstein first wrote down
his theory of curved space-time he said
the most important question that he
needed to look at next was the question
of whether or not there were waves in
the shape of space time if space-time
can curve so let's say you imagine
around the earth around a black hole
there are these deep curves and that
those are the paths that you naturally
fall along if you're falling around a
black hole or the earth or the Sun or
anything else that traces out the shape
of space-time but if i take that black
hole and i start to move it around those
curves in the shape of space have to
follow the moving black hole they have
to somehow readjust straighten out in
some places and curve in other places
and those are the gravitational waves
and they actually move like a wave in
space and time if you were floating
nearby you would kind of Bob on the wave
he would be slightly squeezed and
stretched as it passed and in einstein's
approach to gravity we think that the
gravitational waves travel at the speed
of light so they emanate out through the
universe kind of as though fish were
swirling in a pond and the pond started
to create water waves and those would
emanate out through the ocean when black
holes collide they're like mallets on a
drum and space-time itself rings and if
we could hear that sound which you might
be able to actually technically if
you're an astronaut floating near enough
the colliding black holes you might
actually have your eardrum resonate in
response and hear something and it would
sound well the word that we use is a
chirp it sounds like a chirp and and
what that really means is that the
ringing of space sweeps up in frequency
as the black holes get faster and faster
and finally merged so they're going near
the speed of light by the time it's loud
enough to be heard a gravitational wave
is much closer to a sound than just some
kind of scientific analogy you can take
a lot of different waveforms and
translate them into sound it's it
doesn't really mean that they're
actually sounds but a gravitational wave
is kind of you could liken it to how an
electric guitar when you pluck the
string of an electric guitar it doesn't
tackle
we make a sound it vibrates and the body
of the guitar translates that vibration
into a sound in some sense like oh the
instrument that measured the
gravitational wave it's doing something
like that the gravitational wave is a
ringing of space-time a vibration of
space-time and the Machine Records the
vibration and plays it back a sound you
can actually sit in the control room at
the two sites of the LIGO observatories
and listen to the detector it's
surprising to people I think to know
that gravity is actually very weak we
think that gravity is this incredibly
strong for us we feel heavy and our
chairs we feel heavy when we lie in bed
at night and we we think that somehow
you know gravity's this thing we resist
but it's actually incredibly weak I mean
the whole earth is pulling on me and I
can I can still jump you know and so by
the time the gravitational waves get to
the earth the phenomena is so small that
the experiment has to be incredibly
sensitive to detect this ringing of
space-time presumably right now the room
is flooded with gravitational waves
coming from incredibly far away but
they're just imperceptibly week by the
time that they get here so what the
instrument has to do is it has to record
over four kilometers variations in the
shape of space time of less than one
ten-thousandth the width of a proton
another way to try to have a sense of
that scale is to make the comparison
that it's equivalent to trying to
measure the width of a human hair
compared to a hundred billion times the
circumference of the world even though
LIGO had to record an incredibly quiet
ringing of space-time incredibly subtle
and quiet and it was incredibly
difficult measurement it was from an
event that was the most powerful event
that we've detected since the Big Bang
more power came out of the merger of
those two black holes 1.3 billion years
ago
then all the power and all the star's
luminosity in the entire universe
combined it was the most energetic event
we've detected since the Big Bang so
that's that's really incredible that
none of it came out as far as we know
none of it came out as a light that all
that energy was pushed into the ringing
of space-time and and so the two black
holes when they merged one was about 29
times the mass of the Sun and one was
about 36 times the mass of the Sun when
they merged they made a black hole that
was 62 times the mass of the Sun and
they it they literally shed some of
their mass some of their e equals MC
squared energy into the gravitational
waves the LIGO accomplishment is huge on
many levels but it shouldn't be lost on
us that this is one of the only times
we've recorded something from space that
wasn't brought to us by light so when we
look out into the cosmos we see
everything we see is is shining in one
way or another and whether it's in
x-rays and gamma rays or whether it's an
ultraviolet or infrared light or visible
light it's really the messenger that
that we've relied on to construct what I
think of as kind of a silent movie of
the history of the universe the further
away we look into space the longer ago
that message started its journey to us
so we're looking deep into time and into
space this is the first time we're
recording something like this that isn't
light it's it's really like a soundtrack
to the universe and there are we know
the universe is dark a predominantly
that less than five percent of what's
out there can shine or reflect light
that most of the universe is in a form
of matter called dark matter or a form
of energy called dark energy now maybe
these things don't create gravitational
waves but maybe they do we have a
thought about it hard enough and so this
is not only an opportunity to kind of
turn on the soundtrack to colliding
stars exploding stars the big bang but
it might also be an opportunity to
listen for dark fan
we've really never been able to detect
any other way